uh now we'll hear from i don't know
maybe i could just project
hello hello
yeah okay
all right
uh welcome back uh next we're gonna hear
from the sheet edition at yale who's
gonna tell us about hamiltonian monster
problem
uh hi everyone uh can you hear me
yes
okay great so uh
uh thank you for uh organizing this
online uh so this talk is going to be
on hamiltonian monte carlo which is an
algorithm for sampling from continuous
distributions
um
there is
an accompanying
set of notes that i made available on
the archive uh whose link is here
so uh my plan for this talk is to give a
very gentle introduction to
a certain idealized hamiltonian monte
carlo i presume that some of you here
might not have seen this before
and uh explain explain it from the point
of view of how it might have been
arrived at
give
intuition and even sketches of proofs of
correctness and convergence
for this method
so
let's start with the problem so we are
given a function
f which
which takes the input from some
d-dimensional euclidean space
and our goal is to sample
an input x
from this
gibbs density which is proportional to e
to the minus f of x
i guess this audience doesn't need any
uh
motivation to start with this problem um
it arises in many many different
disciplines
uh and many of the methods that have
been discussed earlier today for
instance by andreas and
by maxim
our iterative methods
and the traditional methods for sampling
from such densities is to use some kind
of a markov chain monte carlo approach
along with the metropolis filter
and at a very high level these
algorithms look like
the following so suppose you are at a
position x i at a point x i in space
and you want to figure out where to go
next
so
perhaps you take some information from
the function it could be the gradient it
could be the scn
or the value of the function
on your current point maybe you add some
noise and you come to a new point
this point is proposed as a possible
point where you would like to jump to
but the metropolis filter applies some
kind of an accept reject
criteria whether you're allowed to jump
or not
and that's how these methods work now
metropolis filter comes in because uh
the goal of the stochastic process is to
have a target i mean the stationary
distribution
should be this density function from
which we are trying to
sample so um
if you just focus on the case of smooth
and strongly uh strongly lock concave pi
which essentially amounts to the
function f being smooth and strongly
convex
and focus on the
the number of evaluations to this
function or its gradient as a function
of the dimension
then
most of these methods
have a dependence which is like d
squared d or root d or something like
that
i guess unlike optimization problems
where we know uh that you can design
optimization methods for functions uh
convex functions strongly converge
functions in bounds which are
independent of d we don't know how to do
this for sampling and that's really the
goal
of the general goal of this
area
i guess it's not possible in full
generality but
trying to understand interesting
conditions where we can go beyond
at least this root d
and perhaps all the way to poly
logarithmic d
would be one of the central goals
of uh algorithms for sampling from such
distributions
so what is hamiltonian monte carlo so
this is an algorithm which is proposed
by physicist uh i believe
uh it somehow magically completely gets
rid of this accept reject step
the problem with the accept reject step
is that
it slows down your chain
you know then depending upon how smooth
the function is
or or how regular the function is you
might end up rejecting
significantly
and especially as the dimension grows
the rejections might grow and so it
slows you down so
i guess an algorithm which does not
require any accept reject step
uh should be
surprising to people who work in this
area and i have not seen this before and
that's what i'm going to tell you about
so let's start by some of the very
basics um
and we'll come to hamiltonian dynamics
in a little bit so this person who
appeared on the first side is not me
it's not my grandfather it's hamilton
it's it's a person uh uh who lived in
you know in the i think the 19th century
so uh
honoring him the hamiltonian uh
is a function
where there are two sets of variables
now so we introduce a new set of
variables corresponding to
the velocity or the momentum so
physicists like to think of it as
momentum because there is mass
however we will focus on we will not
distinguish velocity and momentum
because in our case there is no particle
and even if there is one we just think
of it as mass one
so with that said uh the hamiltonian you
can view as
uh
well we can define first as the function
f of x which is the given function
plus some
in a not so strange looking term half
norm v square where the norm is
euclidean norm
l two norm
uh you can think of this as uh
the f term being
the potential energy corresponding to
the position variables x
and half v squared term being the
kinetic energy corresponding to the
velocity
uh
vector v of the particle
and this particle has uh uh you know so
so once you define a
hamiltonian function h as a function of
both the position and the velocity
hamilton's contribution was to write
down
certain differential equations which
predict how this particle would evolve
for it moving in this
potential well governed by this function
f
and these differential equations uh
which i will explain a little bit more
are something like this they describe
how their position changes over time
and how the velocity of changes over the
time so the velocity changes the
acceleration and that's negative of the
gradient of the potential
and the rate of change of position is
the velocity
so this is not something very deep
however i think it's still useful to
think of it in this way because it
allows us to generalize the viewpoint
and go beyond this euclidean or even the
simple
kinetic energy that we're talking about
here
so given this
the hamiltonian monte carlo algorithm in
in what is called its idealized form
is actually the following
so it's
uh so it has steps steps are indexed by
i in each step let's say the ith step
it samples a random gaussian vector in
the dimensions
this thing here
z
and it simulates
a deterministic hamiltonian the
deterministic hamiltonian dynamics
starting at this
position x i with a random velocity
c
for some time t which is a parameter of
this algorithm
and here you can see a little give if
it's clear if it's not that's okay
so from time to time the particle is
stopped and its velocity is
refreshed
so it's really as simple as that
so the only thing that we have to figure
out
is what time t shall we pick uh and
that's really what we are going to focus
most of our time in this talk
but even before that a very basic uh an
interesting fact which uses all the
properties of uh
dynamics
is the fact that this
this stochastic process
preserves
this density which is e to the minus f
of x minus
half v square which is nothing but
e to the minus the hamiltonian
in the uh in the position and velocity
space
so the position is a d dimensional
vector the velocity is also a
dimensional vector together sometimes
they are referred to as the phase space
so the hamiltonian is a function of the
phase space of the particle
so
what we will show is that this fact is
true
which is
uh
uh which is quite interesting
and this is the reason why people
thought that it might be a good idea to
try to run this algorithm of course the
obvious problem is
how to simulate
this hamiltonian dynamics these are
continuous
uh
differential equations
or a continuous time dynamical system
uh we can't really
do this in a computer
so we will need to discretize
uh these trajectories
um using some kind of approximations
numerical approximations and that
um you know so so so once you do that i
mean that's another whole thing which
i'm going to just kind of briefly
mention at the end of the talk
and with these discretizations
people use this algorithm
quite widely
so what i mean by this is the following
that if you let's say pick a point x
comma v from this density in the phase
space
and you take one step of the hamiltonian
monte carlo
which is in the first sub step you
refresh the velocity
and in the second sub step you do
hamiltonian dynamics for
any time t actually
then
and when you look at the new x tilde and
v tilde that you are at
the density of that point is the same as
the starting density that's what i mean
and i will make this clear and i'll also
give a proof of this
does that answer your question yes
okay
so uh yeah i guess we're not going to go
too much into discretization we are
going to look at the elegant mathematics
and physics that underlie this algorithm
and my hope is to communicate uh that to
you and hopefully you will study this
more
in the semester
and find connections with other
topics that are being discussed
so here is a picture
just to kind of give you a visual sense
you already saw a gif but if the gif was
not visible then this is really what is
happening
so x1 is the position
z1 is the velocity that you
kick it with it moves for some time
[Music]
i mean it's there's no other
uh you know there's nothing else it
keeps moving uh based on the potential
well
at some point
after time capital t you stop this
particle and you kick it again
in and not in the direction where it was
going this is the direction it was going
but you just give it a random
turn again and you keep repeating that
so that's what is happening
and at this point you should ask why are
we stopping this particle
um
how long should we how frequently should
we stop it how long do we let it go and
so on i mean these are the kind of
questions we will try to
to but i mean okay so i saw this
algorithm a few years ago and i was
fully mesmerized i should tell you
um having worked in this area i mean
this seemed
completely bizarre to me why something
like this should work
and why is this a good idea
so hopefully i'll give you some
intuition about that
what time
hello
is there a question
okay um
so so let's review hamiltonian dynamics
um
and yeah just feel free to interrupt me
if you have any questions i mean this
slide will uh be a one slide crash
course of hamiltonian dynamics
i can spend um
time to explain if something is not
clear
so we view
a particle which is moving
in rd
and we denote we use x t to denote its
position
um but really the particle also has some
velocity
which is again a vector in rd
so you should really think of
the point as moving in a 2d dimensional
space or the 2d dimensional phase space
so we're going to unders
to see once we define a function
h
in this phase space
which outputs a real number given a
vector in two dimensions
hamilton
wrote down these equations which are
very generic so i just write it down
here for this particular hamiltonian you
can think of
very complicated hamiltonian in
particular if you start allowing this
norm by which you're measuring the
length of v
to depend on the position x
okay
then
you start getting what is called the
riemannian hamiltonian monte carlo which
i'm not going to talk about but for
people who would know
i think this question kind of came up in
andrea's talk so i just wanted to make a
slight remark here
that you can consider very general
functions you can consider non-separable
things and so on
and you will see the limitations uh
computationally once you think more
about it
but once you have a hamiltonian
hamilton's equations were the following
that the rate of change of the position
so at you know this is how the the
particle will evolve now in the phase
space dx by dt
is the partial derivative of h with
respect to the part uh with respect to
the the velocity vectors
which in this simple hamiltonian just
turns out to be v
and you can view this as again velocity
or momentum
and the rate of change of velocity which
is acceleration or if you multiply it
with mass then it becomes force
uh this
hamilton said that this should be equal
to the negative of the partial
derivative of the hamiltonian with
respect to x
um
and in this simple case it turns out to
be nothing but the negative gradient of
the function at your current point
and
this
yeah this this starts looking more and
more like newton's law in this very
newton's newton's law this very simple
case
that force is equal to you know
the negative of the potential and this
is just a trivial equation
so what are the properties of this so
there are three interesting properties
one is time reversibility which is
generally satisfied by all classical
mechanics
second would be the preservation of
the hamiltonian itself on trajectories
and third will be something really
interesting which will be the
preservation of uh volume
so i'm going to tell you about all these
three things all of them are relatively
simple to prove
but i'll still go over slowly over them
so that in case you have questions
please feel free to interrupt and ask
so time reversibility uh means the
following
suppose you start at a point x with the
velocity v
and you move for some time t
and you reach some new point x prime
uh
x prime v prime
so you reach at a point x prime and you
note the velocity vector v prime now
just reverse the velocity vector in the
opposite direction
and go back the same time
you're going to reach back at the point
you started off
started at with the negative of the
velocity you started at
okay i'll let you absorb this for 10
seconds
it's saying something very simple
um
that
i mean that there is this kind of
symmetry with respect to time in these
dynamics
that you can
uh
you can you can go from a point
for some time
reach another point with some velocity
just reverse the velocity and go back
the same time or go forward the same
time and you reach the same point back
with the velocity and pointing in the
opposite direction
the second property is uh what is called
hamiltonian conservation
and this
is uh
okay so i should also mention here
that this hamiltonian that i have
defined here does not depend on time in
principle you could consider
hamiltonians that depend on time
and
they will not satisfy this property
okay
so this this this condition holds only
for hamiltonians where there is no time
component in them
there's no kind of friction if you want
to imagine
so
the preservation of hamiltonian
along hamilton along the trajectory just
says that the time derivative of this
hamiltonian
is zero
and why is that true so we can just use
the chain rule
and write down the hamiltonian's
derivative
as
summation over all its components
of
the the rate of change of the ith
position vector times the change of the
hamiltonian with respect to the
ith uh position variable
plus the same thing for the velocity
and this is zero
because
you can
just
plug in these equations here so dv by dt
is the negative of the hamiltonian with
respect to x
and dx by dt is the
positive partial of h with partial with
respect to v
if i
use these two sets of equations which
are really vector equations and plug
them here coordinate by coordinate
i get a term by term cancellation for
every term on this first summation there
is exactly one term with a negative sign
in the second
and so you get a zero
so this is uh yeah this is uh this is
easy
what may not be so straightforward to uh
to do this
being easy using multivariate calculus
is that the hamiltonian also preserves
volume in the phase space so let me
first explain what this means before i
write down mathematically
what this means is the following that
you have this 2d dimensional space
the phase space
you take a small volume element
and now do the following for every point
in this
in this set you you you compute the
trajectory and see where you end up
after some time t
and you do this for every point so this
volume here
will move in the phase space this volume
element here will move in the phase
space
and
this volume preservation property really
says that the volume is invariant
so while it may happen that if you just
look at the volume restricted to the
position space or just look at the
volume restricted to the velocity space
this can fluctuate widely
but
the volume in the phase space doesn't
change
so to prove that
it's also really a tuple of line
calculation
um
so there are multiple ways to prove that
prove this
one is to just compute the push forward
measure and look at the
the jacobian and you can see that the
retraction determinant of something is
one
perhaps the more calculus way to see
this is to now in the phase space rd
cross rd
at the point xv you define this vector
field
uh dx by dt and dv by dt
and you compute the divergence of this
vector here so divergence is this
uh
i mean this thing here
and again uh you can check i mean you
can just
see from from these equations that if i
plug this stuff in
i get
uh
i get zero and divergence is a
mathematical quantity which measures
whether there are sources or sinks in a
vector field and divergence being 0
everywhere
is equivalent to saying
that
the volume under these uh you know so
the volume element as as it moves
uh in this vector field according to
this vector field doesn't change
any questions uh about these basic
properties of hamiltonian dynamics
okay so let's keep moving uh this
idea
of volume preservation in the face space
actually is very very general
it's all looks very specific in the
setting of the uh
hamilton's equation but there is this
whole area of mathematics called
sympathetic geometry
who
whose goal is to generalize
um this property
of
hamiltonian dynamics
to
more complicated objects
like manifolds for instance
and
so that once you have some function from
that manifold
uh
there is and more or less automatic way
to define hamiltonian vector fields or
or to understand how trajectories of
particles in that phase space would move
so i'm not going to go so much into this
but for people who want to look it up
this is a very interesting branch of
mathematics
which i'm sure will show up uh in this
program
as well
okay so let's go back to the idealized
hamiltonian monte carlo and
let's try to state
what we are going to see in this lecture
today
so
everything here is the same as slides
that you saw before except that i have
just included one more notation here
which is this verify sub t
uh
and this is nothing but
the
hamiltonian flow in the phase space so
this function just gives you
the position and the velocity after time
capital t once you start from this
position and this velocity
uh i hope you can see my cursor
as well so
um
yes
okay
so
so the first
thing that we're going to prove is that
this hamiltonian monte carlo preserves
the density function
and the second thing we are going to see
is
some convergence bounds
in particular when the function is
strongly convex and smooth
then essentially its condition number
determines the convergence time in the
velocity distance
okay um this is a result that was so
what i'm going to show you is actually
from
an adaptation from the paper of mangubi
and smith which the where the dependence
is condition number squared
but actually i'm going to show you
something a simplification of this where
the dependence is really just the
condition number
which was proved in full generality by
chen and vampire in 2019
and
theorem also tells you exactly how long
you can run this
process
for and there is a reason i mean you'll
see a very uh
reason why we cannot
run it for for for very very long but i
think the point to really note and drive
home here is that there is no dimension
dependence here whatsoever
okay so this is uh i i don't know of any
other family of algorithms maybe there
are but i don't know
um where where
we have this kind of property
yes
uh i'm curious why you're emphasizing
the lack of dimension defensive because
to me it seems this is like the
continuous time process and if you look
at the continuous timeline
process it should also converge with
like continuous time that has no
intervention
like is it all the dimension dependence
and sampling
yes but continuous time but the
continuous time longitude dynamics is uh
actually choosing i mean it's it's
adding noise
uh at every iteration i mean like it's
here i think that maybe maybe i should
clarify this i mean what this really
means is that
uh
you you
so it also i mean so okay so one
difference between longevan and
hamiltonian monte carlo is that
the continuous time longevan actually
keeps choosing a different velocity at
every
time
here we just choose the velocity at the
beginning of each phase and then let it
run it's a completely deterministic
process for a very long time well by a
very long time i mean something like a
constant which is independent of the
dimension
so maybe it is i mean so to me it was
surprising maybe it's not surprising to
some people so
um but i um but yeah i think this is the
this is the lack of the dimension
dependence here
is what
led people to think that perhaps we can
derive dimension free sampling
algorithms from this of course when we
start discretizing we will lose some of
it
but
in the end i would say a few words about
it
okay so
let's look at the first uh
first property
that hmc preserves the target density
so
what do we want to prove here
uh we want to prove the following
so suppose you were to sample so we are
in rd cross rd so there's a base measure
and so
you know the density is with respect to
that base measure so we sample this
point x comma v
from this density with respect to the
base measure
and then we take one step of hmc and by
one step again i mean that in the first
you just throw away the velocity
sample a random velocity and then that's
step one a if you may and then step one
b would be to now run
hamiltonian dynamics which is a
deterministic process for time capital t
so what i would like to prove here
and the proof will be
fit in this slide
is
that
the point x tilde v tilde that you end
up at for any t
will also have the same density i mean
that's what it means for the density to
be invariant
so then you may ask you know why do we
need to even resample why don't we just
keep doing this
any any ideas why
i don't know if i'm allowed to ask
questions to the audience but
but maybe at least just to kind of slow
it down a little bit
if something like this were true if you
believe something like this why do we
have any meters to to keep
refreshing the velocity
so because what you actually want is the
sample from
uh you want you want to sample on on x
right at the end so there it's there's
some some issue where as you as you
evolve the distribution of x and b
separately will change because
no
you can just ignore v at the end
because if it is indeed true
that xb was xtilde v tilde is sampled
from pi
remember that pi has this form
uh which is fi i mean this for this
particular hamiltonian the distribution
is uh
uh you know you can just ignore v and
you'll get the right marginal that
you're looking for
well i mean here for you the issue is i
guess that the hamiltonian is preserved
so if you don't update v you're always
sampling that energy surface right
right
yeah i think ergodicity is the concern
also right i mean that we we will not be
given us i mean so the whole premise is
uh spurious here we will not be given a
sample from pi
uh we will have to somehow start from
some arbitrary point
and then
uh slowly move towards this target
density
um
i'm just pointing out these things to to
kind of illustrate the difference
between differences between hmc and some
of the other
standard mcmc algorithms
yeah so we need to kind of bypass the
fact that actually
the energy is preserved um because
and we should be able to kind of reach
the target density no matter where we
start from
but anyway let's first look at this uh
this property
so
there are two steps the first the
refreshing velocity step let's look at
that
first this is uh
yeah this is uh the easier part
so we pick the psi independent of
everything independent of all the sides
we have picked in the past and
independent of the current position
and
and because it has the same marginal
uh and i mean in some sense that is the
reason why we are picking psi from the
normal distribution
if for instance uh and let me make this
remark here if for instance you would
have picked a different hamiltonian
where
for example instead of half v square you
had some local norm and you were
measuring the length of v with respect
to that local norm
then you would have to pick
from the corresponding marginal so that
adds this extra computational burden on
you sampling from a gaussian is
very simple but sampling from something
uh
you know which is distributed according
to
rimanian metric might be harder
so
so there is a direct relation between
this half v square
and the covariance matrix in this
in fact the covariance matrix here is
just the uh
the the you know the hessian of this
quadratic form
so
so this is kind of by design so that's
the reason why in fact we are sampling
uh to have this property that once we
kind of replace it
and if if yeah if for whatever reason
you chose some different hamiltonian
then we would have sample psi from the
corresponding
normal distribution with an appropriate
covariance matrix
okay so this part i think is uh should
be easy
to to follow and doesn't really use any
property of hamiltonian dynamics so far
the second part is where we're going to
use
all the properties that we have talked
about so far and one additional property
so when now we have this z
the random velocity that we just added
and now we simulated the hamiltonian
dynamics for time capital t and we
reached this point x delta v tilde
now x tilde we tilted the deterministic
function of these things
um
so first let's observe that
using the symmetry of h with respect to
the velocity component time
reversibility of the hamiltonian and the
hamiltonian conservation we get the
sequence of equality which i'm going to
explain
so the first equality is just saying
that the hamiltonian does not change
whether we have uh
if we reverse the sign of the velocity
our vector our hamiltonian
is just half z square so it doesn't
really change if i plug in zero minus
so we do this first
then
we use the time reversibility to note
that if i started from x tilde in the
direction minus v tilde
and ran for capital time t i will reach
x minus z
so this point here x minus z is the same
as
this thing inside
so this red thing here is a consequence
a consequence of time reversibility
and then
we have uh
because this is just uh
you know so now here you started at x
tilde minus v tilde and ran hamiltonian
dynamics for time t
we know that hamiltonian dynamics
preserves the hamiltonian
so we recover h of x tilde minus v tilde
and now we can again use the symmetry of
the hamiltonian to get x tilde
so
we have used two out of the three
properties of the hamiltonian dynamics
to argue
that
the hamiltonian at your starting point
is the same as the hamiltonian at your
ending point for all t
okay i asked a question
um
why did you need to invoke the type
reversibility here it seems like it
should just be
conservation
i'm sorry
why why did you need to invoke time time
reversibility here like is it this just
a consequence of the hamiltonian
conservation
um
i mean i want to compare the hamiltonian
at this point
to the hamiltonian at this point so i
need some way to relate
these things
and this is not a time
unless i'm missing something here this
is not a
yeah so this to do this we need to go
via this intermediate step
he's suggesting you start from the right
and you just replace x delta v tilde by
phi t of x psi and then you just remove
the spike c
the phi t
and then you just have h of x i which is
your left hand side
um
yeah perhaps you could do that um
you still have to set x total
right like
you start from the right
where your assistant you're still trying
to matter
be told at some point
all you know is the the forward mapping
yeah yeah so i write i start on the
right and i just talk about the
pre-image of the map
yeah so i think time reversibility is a
first of all it's a trivial fraction of
a defect and you the pre-image you do
need some kind of inversion i mean
there's not some crazy function i think
that's all you need here
perhaps you will need something if you
try to do that formally
um
i mean there is another way to see why
you need time reversibility right which
is probably more apparent in this uh
this line that i'm going to say
and suppose now you partition the the
phase space into these infinite symbol
cubes now i'm giving you a more graphic
proof of this fact
right so you're partitioning you
partition the space phase space into
very small cubes and they are so small
that
in each cube the value of the
hamiltonian is constant
okay
and now let's say you move this
this cube in time
so
the volume preservation thing tells us
that the volume doesn't change the
hamiltonian preservation tells us that
the hamiltonian doesn't change so the
density doesn't change as long as
trajectories don't collide
so there has to be like a one to oneness
in this
so if if if trajectory start colliding
uh then there is a problem here
so it's it's just
it's some invertibility thing that's all
uh it's it's not very deep if i were to
say which of the three conditions
is uh most important here i would say
the volume one is the most important
um
and then the hamiltonian one and then
the time reverse but i mean i think they
are all uh all necessary as far as i can
tell but i'll i'll get back to uh if you
send me an email who will ask this
question we can take it offline from
there
okay so this is essentially i mean this
is a sketch but this is pretty precise
you can make it into a formal argument
if you really are not convinced at this
point that this is uh
um this is this is what is going on
and from here you can also see that uh
this argument will not apply in just the
face in just the position space or just
a velocity space
because the volume conservation is only
in the phase space
you have to do this argument in the face
space
okay so let's uh let's get to to the
running time bounce
um
whether how i'm doing on how am i doing
on time just to get a sense of uh
how quick or slow
it's uh 4 14.
okay
so 15 minutes or or less
yes
okay
okay so so what we're going to do is uh
uh
when we when we move towards convergence
bounds
uh we're going to use the idea of
coupling
so this is not new to people here uh i
presume
you have two markov chains
uh with the same transition kernel we're
going to construct a coupling
which is contractive
and
and the idea
is
uh
yeah without any kind of uh
further due
the the coupling that we are going to do
is actually a very natural coupling once
you start thinking of the process from
physics point of view
um
so there is i mean so there is one
choice of randomness at this point x1
which is what uh velocity to pick and
you have the same choice here at y1 x1
and y1 are two different positions
um what we do is at every time step we
associate the same velocity
uh initial velocity
of course these velocities will change
as
as the particle moves
uh the trajectories are different so by
the time it reaches x2 and y2
the
velocity vectors will no longer be the
same
okay
so what shall we do uh in the beginning
the velocities are the same
what we would like to understand is how
long will these things keep moving
uh
so that there is some kind of a
contraction
between their positions
at some point they will probably
so so they will come i mean so this is
something i'm going to show you first
and then uh give you kind of an uh a
proof of this that for some initial time
they will come close to each other these
two points given the fact that they have
the same velocity this has to do with
the geometry of the space we are in
and we will get an estimate of that time
as long as we can prove that the
particles are coming close we will let
them keep going
and once we
when we are not sure we are going to
stop both of them and
pick a random velocity and give it the
same velocity to both so they will come
back even they'll come closer even more
come keep coming closer closer closer
until they collide
and the key fact is that you can for
strongly convex and smooth potentials
you can prove a contraction which is
independent of the dimension
um i'm going to show essentially the
essence of this proof via a harmonic
oscillator the proof almost immediately
generalizes
um
[Music]
um
so
feedback from so can you see can you see
this animation is it visible
no yes it's not really moving oh maybe
it's because yeah
oh it's not moving okay but we see the
bar now okay yeah
that works
so what is happening here is that there
are these two pendulums uh
which which ideal pendulums which red
and the blue one which we start off with
the same velocity at different positions
but with the same velocity
and
you can from your own intuition even if
you cannot see this from your own
intuition you you should be able to kind
of guess that
for a very short time however small it
is the two pendulums are going to get
closer
uh
and then they will diverge again so what
we really want is an estimate on
what is this time where we can guarantee
that these things come close
so let's look at the absolute vanilla
case which is the case of a spherical
harmonic oscillator and then we're going
to go from the spherical to a general
harmonic oscillator
so here the function is just
half of x transpose x which is just
you know
half of norm x squared
and the gradient of this is just x so we
will generalize this in the next slide
the setting where there is even a
diagonal matrix here which is where
which assigns different weights to
different coordinates but let's just
look at this simple case to get the
intuition and even if you understand
this slide i think that's already my job
more than eighty percent done
um and so let's give some uh let's
introduce some notation
so we have these uh
particles
one we are indexing with x and v and the
other one we're indexing with y and u
both
start off at different positions capital
x capital y but with the same velocity z
and this is what where things are at
after time t
so let's look at uh
the second derivative of the change the
difference in the position coordinates
okay
so just by linearity this is just the
change of the rate of change of the
velocity of the first
minus the change of velocity of the
second this is just the acceleration of
the difference
because you want to argue you know
when is the difference getting smaller i
mean both particles both pendulums
seem to be moving away so we can only
argue that they're getting closer which
means the distance is getting small
so if you just plug in the formulas uh
here
i mean the hamiltonian dynamics we get
that the rate of change of velocity is
minus negative the gradient of the
function
the gradient in this case is just x so
the x is a vector here but nevertheless
it's just x
so what we get is the second order
ode
that
the second time derivative of some
quantity is equal to the negative of the
same quantity this is exactly harmonic
oscillator or the string that i'm sure
we're all studying in high school in a
physics course
and we all know what happens here
since the particles were started at the
same with the same momentum or velocity
we have one boundary condition which is
that the rate of change of the
difference is zero
and so you can just solve it
analytically
and you get that x t minus y t behaves
like cosine of t
times the initial difference now this is
not zero
but after time t which is pi by two
this will be zero
because pi by two is zero i hope i got
this right
and as a consequence x t minus y t is
zero
so
this actually shows a single step
contraction in one step you're going to
hit this other thing
of course this is a very idealized
situation
but at least you get
some simple toy example where things are
contracting
and this is something
i believe
doesn't require more than
very basic uh
math
okay let's let's do a slightly more uh
tricky case
which is
which is also not very far away from the
general case of smooth and lock concave
potentials any questions
i have a question um
so if i'm understanding a factory does
that mean you have to tune the time like
appropriately
yes absolutely we are trying to get an
estimate on time
um
and we will see already in the next
example that we this time will not be pi
by 2 it will start depending upon the
diagonal matrix that we're going to plug
in here
yeah that's our goal to get a bound on
a time
uh that the largest t that we can get
where we have contraction
we know we have instantaneous
contraction that that can be proved in a
variety of ways uh because
the space has kind of geometry where
trajectories initially point towards
each other
but
we want to get kind of non
quantitative bounds
that's what we're trying to get here
so now let's look at this more general
harmonic oscillator where we have a
diagonal matrix c
where all c i's are positive they are
not the same but they are
uh upper bounded by capital m so so
let's say all c i's are between small m
and capital m
uh which is the case we are trying to
mimic of
if the function was strongly convex then
its hessian at any point will be at
least small m times identity and upper
bounded by capital m time identity if it
was capital m smooth
so we can do the same calculation we
will follow the same recipe compute the
second derivative of the difference in
the position
with respect to time
now instead of the identity here
we get this matrix c there's a factor of
2 here because i dropped the half
that's you can ignore that that's not
going to make such a big difference
now because c is positive
this has a component in the direction of
y t minus x t this is important to note
here
if c was not positive these things may
not converge
but because he's positive
there will be
so the time derivative squared of this
quantity here will have some component
in this direction yt minus xt so if
there is an attractive force
and as a consequence
i mean very roughly if two particles
start with the same velocity they will
move towards each other at this rate
uh you don't have to understand how i
came up with this but you it will not
take you more than a minute to figure
this out if you
just sit down and do this for yourself
so there will be contraction so that's
uh but how there is a problem because we
are not in the case where um
in the identity case essentially
um so it's not like it's constant times
identity
it's
it could have potentially different
numbers on the diagonal
it also has components which are not in
the direction of x t minus
y t and that will tend to kind of pull
these things away quickly
however
these odes are separable
along the coordinate directions and for
every j
we can write down this evolution
equation second order equations
where now these are real numbers
x t j and y t j these are the jth
coordinates of these vectors
so this case is very similar to the the
to the thing we just did before
instead of cos t you're going to get cos
of square root 2 times c jt so that's
the solution to this
we know that
cj is bounded by capital m for all j and
so the contraction will happen till
about
this time now since so instead of
uh
pi by 2 we lose
essentially inversely proportional to
the square root of
the bound we have on how large
some
c can
be um
and we also have a lower bound on these
cj's we know that each cj is at least
some small m
so we can also get
uh basically this kind of a bound
um that contraction
uh
so for
for up till the time it contracts the
contraction can be bounded by something
like this
and this is a number which is less than
one
you can use a very simple inequality
involving cosine of a number s
and
as a consequence obtain a coordinate
wise contraction that then gives you a
vector right contraction
of something like 1 over inverse of the
condition number
and that's it
so
we have a contraction which is like 1
minus
m by m
or small m by capital m
and so we will converge in times of the
capital m by m or the condition number
of this potential
and this generalizes to the to the full
case by essentially some simple
comparison theorems that
you will lose uh an additional factor of
kappa in the analysis that i presented
in the notes
but it's also not the tightest analysis
i said that you can actually get kappa
as chen and vampala did for the for the
general case as well
um
[Music]
any questions
sorry there's no t in this right hand
side anymore you just upper bounded by a
capital t
um
no no so t is bounded by uh
you know so there is a t sorry i think
uh
so t is bounded by this quantity here
so this con this happens for t up till
this capital t which is pi by two by one
over root two
so up till this time you have
contraction and that contraction is this
much
i had a question also
can you share the intuition for why
initially
uh trajectories point towards one
another
um
in general i guess
uh yeah so these things are true very
generally actually on even uh for very
general hamiltonians so so you have to
do a curvature calculation for that
uh essentially
and the curvature turns out to have the
right sign
for for
for positive geometries
um i think these are called the roche
theorem or something like that in
iranian geometry
so
yeah i can point to uh
uh
to the precise uh place where you can
find just theorems
but yeah there is uh yeah i should
i mean i didn't want to make it very
complicated mathematically
but yeah there is already some reason to
believe that there will be at least
instantaneous contraction
but i mean it's very it's asked it is
essentially as simple in local
coordinates as this equation if locally
the equation of evolution looks like
you know the second derivative is minus
d2 x by dt coming into z by dt square is
minus 2z then you know the contraction
so just uh one clarification so the
reason why
so it's just a matter of the proof
technique here so if you were in 1d you
would have a t at which they actually
collide exactly and you would probably
think that's correct
that's right and uh actually you
wouldn't do anything you would just
analyze it this way but for your
coupling but the here like the two
pendulum
in in high dimensions are actually never
touching each other is that what's
happening
that's right and in fact that's a very
good point i should have mentioned that
if the if your potential if you were to
sample from a gaussian distribution
using this method you will do it in one
step
okay because that's what this the
harmonic oscillator corresponds to the
spherical harmonic curve
so this exactly corresponds to sampling
from a gaussian density if you because
remember that our goal was to sample
from e to the minus f of x and this is
already a hard case for many previous
algorithms
okay so i have a follow-up question this
is i'm just hoping you're not gonna go
so this morning andreas mentioned the
fact that uh you know you can use this
coupling where you're just canceling out
the noise for each of those parts so
here you're cancelling out by taking the
same velocity for the the
in each of the realizations yeah and the
same thing eventually you could actually
try to have those velocities pointing
towards each other right like just
drawing two correlated gaussians that
are pointing to each other and use the
noise that actually gets faster there is
there anything
is there anything you hope to gain or
there's actually really nothing to gain
beyond what you already have like no i
think it's a it's a good question and
this is still not uh fully understood
thing i must say
so
for example
is there that you could actually get
there because you don't you're only
going to get contraction from your
potential from the from the
deterministic part right you need to
actually
you hope to you you should hope to get
it from the stochastic part
so here you assume that your lowest
eigenvalue is is bounded away from zero
right
that's right it's it's a small m yeah
yeah
yeah i think that so so that has to do
with uh also the curvature of the uh you
know the x space essentially yeah
okay since i think i'm out of time i'll
just mention a few words about an
integrator and uh then proceed to
concluding the talk
so for for those of you who uh probably
uh would say you know okay all this
sounds great i mean you know how do we
actually implement this
so even there there are some very
beautiful integrators uh ways to
discretize hamiltonian dynamics which is
very unusual
um i mean you could the first thing that
should come to somebody's mind is why
don't we just do euler discretization
first order or second order
discretization
i just want to write these formulas in
front of you without kind of trying to
explain this to you
that there are these kind of
discretizations or integrators as they
are called
where
you don't lose all the good properties
of the continuous dynamics so in
particular there is something called the
symplectic integrator
where
even though the trajectories that it
produces are not the trajectories of the
hamiltonian dynamics exactly
yet it conserves the volume which turned
out to be one of the key things uh in
our analysis
um and that that ensures that the
measure is being pushed forward in the
phase space in in the right manner
and it also uh approximately
conserves the hamiltonian so i can't say
much more than that
um
as you can see these integrators require
like really one gradient call i mean
there are two gradients here but one is
from the previous iteration and one is
the new iteration
uh the real question is can we now give
some kind of a bound on eta
and for this i'm gonna just uh mention
one of my results perhaps that's the
reason why i was asked to give this talk
that we can get d to the one fourth
uh gradient evaluations which is beyond
the root b bound
with this leapfrog integrator
under certain regularity assumptions and
i'm gonna think i'm gonna skip the
regularity assumptions and just mention
that these regularity assumptions were
inspired by certain bayesian inference
applications that appear in machine
learning
okay so
if you didn't follow any of this stuff
uh the the take home is that
discretizing hamiltonian trajectories is
an equally interesting topic in itself
perhaps can be a a talk in one of the
workshops or else you know
else during another time in the semester
um
and the punch line is when we want to
discretize
continuous time trajectories there is
more that
more you could possibly do than just
doing euler or taylor series
discretization
that's that's a take home for the
general audience here
so to conclude uh
hmc
uh
is this the sampling algorithm that
really uses ideas from classical physics
uh in the ideal case which i presented
there is no need for a metropolis step
giving it the promise to be fast and
possibly have a small dimension
independent running time
uh i talked about the second order or at
least i flashed to the second order
discretization
there are also higher order
discretizations uh by gintart lee and
santosh impala and others
um
you should look at which can get these
bounds even better
uh from d to the one fourth you can go
down to d to the one over two times
l where l is
essentially
the bound on the lth order derivatives
of the potential function
lots of recent work on it
riemannian manifolds if you if you're
interested in learning how to do hmc
only monument manifolds while the lien
vampire paper does not really introduce
the riemann hmc it gives a non-synthetic
bound for
uh for for in this setting
uh if you want to
to
to to look at so one of the issues which
i flashed through was that once you
start doing discretizations you start
getting running time bounds which depend
one over epsilon as opposed to log one
over epsilon as in the continuous case
so for that you'll have to metropolize
the hmc again
uh you don't lose everything you can
still get pretty good algorithms you can
look at this paper background c chen and
others
from berkeley uh who might be there
and
andrea severle and his co-authors have
this very nice result
which
shows coupling arguments which go beyond
convexity
i guess i'll just conclude by saying
that physics and physical systems have
been and can be a great source and ideas
for algorithms for optimization and
sampling
and you will see more examples of this
on friday in the boot camp with this
i'll stop and
take any questions thank you
any questions
okay
yeah
so
from the lecture in the morning there
were actually like two different
techniques for analyzing algorithm and
one of them was like using
functional inequalities
and i was just wondering whether
you can also like consider
like a continuous version of like uh
agency
by just considering like the noises i
injected like continuously
and somehow like analyze it using like
functional employees to achieve like uh
right that becomes a language dynamics
actually so uh if i
if i
make this time capital t
to be close to zero then it starts
converging towards
large journey dynamics
and for which we we do know how to do
the kind of analysis that you're talking
about
so
my impression from speaking to
practitioners which is a sort of
constant with your uh
result and the hmc is spectacular for
something from universal distribution
and for
if you want to sample from something
that is multimodal it is a disaster so i
guess i
i'm wondering maybe you thought about
this also
uh do you have any ideas for
this sort of sympathetic dynamics style
sampling algorithm to work for
uh
starting this paper of burabi berlin
zimmer does talk about multimodal
distributions
uh so i would uh i'm not an expert in
either practice or
uh theory of
of these things so i i wouldn't comment
on that but i'll just point you to this
paper which is i think a very
interesting paper
which talks about which gives coupling
bounds
for multimodal distributions and i think
but from what i understand is and
talking to some people who work in
chemistry and use these methods in
simulating molecular dynamics i
understand that the landscape they are
very very
uh
[Music]
you know non-convex
whatever that means
and
they are somehow able to use hmc type
methods
to get to simulate you know
whatever they want it for
however they do use dimensionality
reduction methods in this so
in practice i guess the situation is far
more complex than
anything that
you have seen at least in this talk
but thanks for that question
yeah i will certainly think more about
it after after your question
yeah certainly
just like if
uh the the thing with say uh stochastic
radio descent or electrical dynamics or
something so if you have you know a
particle that's stuck in one mode and
you need to get to the other mode every
step you're injecting noise right
whereas with agency you have to wait
to capital t every time to have another
chance of getting it to hop over to the
other well right that's the sort of my i
understand heuristic understanding
what's the problem for agency type of
methods with this
yeah and i should also mention andre
estreschi
who's
i think visiting this semester
also has
thought about this with i think holden
lee and others
uh on this multi-modal thing so he will
also be a good person to talk to
uh
i think he already has some results on
this topic
but yeah
for multi-modal sampling from
multi-modal densities
andrew you need to post it on this court
because this is going to disappear with
uh
with the talk
all right is there any more questions
all right let's thank our speaker
[Applause]
thank you
so